ANNOUNCER: Ladies and gentlemen,
the 45th and final
President of the United States.
(cheering and applause)
-(camera shutters clicking)
-Yeah.
(reporters clamoring)
Thank you. Thank you.
What an incredible turnout.
First, let me just say,
when you look
at the tragic events in Houston
and you look into the faces
of these people
who have lost everything,
I think we can all agree:
this has been my best week yet!
I mean, look at me--
I get to talk in a truck!
Sir, we can see
that's not a real truck.
Yeah, that's right, dummy.
It's a fire truck.
And I got my raincoat
and my hat.
Isn't it cool?
I look like I'm helping!
How can you congratulate
yourself at a time like this?
I'm not congratulating myself.
We're not gonna do that
until this is all over
and cleaned up
in two, three days max.
I want to ask you
about North Korea.
You tweeted that "talking
is not the answer." So what is?
I don't know the answer,
but I do know the question.
And that question is,
"What is the answer?"
-What? Are you kidding?
-What does that mean?
Exactly. Next question.
Okay. Do you support your
party's idea to cut $1 billion
from disaster funds
to pay for your border wall?
Of course! The wall would've
prevented this entire thing.
I mean,
where did Harvey come from?
The Gulf of where?
Where?
Mexico.
You said it, not me!
It's an illegal storm.
They're sending
their worst winds,
their hardest rains.
They're some bad storm-bres.
-That makes no sense!
-This is not real!
You can't be mean to me!
I'm wearing my raincoat.
I'm a storm-time president.
I'm steering the ship,
I'm leading the truck.
And that's why tonight's theme
is leadertruck.
I mean, leadership.
Toot, toot! Honk, honk!
I'm the president!
Can you relief it? Let's roll!